foreign
to the press conference following the
tripartite social Summit Madam president
you are the first one to take thank you
very much indeed we had a very
productive meeting a very good
three apartheid social Summit
and it was symbolic I think and it
showed the strength of our cooperation
the discussion today confirmed that we
have more or less a common view on
competitiveness and the importance of
competitiveness
and competitiveness in a sense that it
ensures on one hand prosperity and
growth and on the other hand quality
jobs in Europe so what the Hallmark of
our social market economy is and this is
happening against the backdrop of
growing challenges through climate
change
so our first Focus was on the proposals
tabled by the commission last week and
this is mainly the focus on the clean
tech industry our green deal industrial
plan we discussed with the social
Partners the proposals to keep Europe in
a pole position in the clean tech
economy and to secure good quality jobs
in Europe
and it is very clear from our discussion
we also felt Europe has to accelerate
this is the essence of the Net Zero
industry act with the Net Zero industry
act we want to make the European Union
the home of cleantech Industry we're
sitting setting clear targets and we're
planning to achieve the targets with
speed with simplification and with
funding
so this is a very clear message to our
clean tech sector and for Quality jobs
in Europe
the second proposal is about the
critical raw materials Act
to succeed in the green and digital
transition we need to secure access to
critical raw materials we need to
strengthen and diversify our supply
chains
so the critical raw material acts look
act looks at what is needed domestically
to improve refining processing and very
important important the recycling of
critical raw materials in Europe but it
also looks of course at the global stage
for example the proposal to create a
critical raw materials club with
reliable partners
and important for the topic of reliable
Partners is that it will bring jobs in
our industry but also to our reliable
partners with high standards for working
conditions and protection of the
environment this is in connection with
the critical romance periods crucial and
essential for us
centerpiece of our discussions was the
topic of skills
we need a skilled Workforce to create
and keep quality jobs in Europe and
those jobs need to be attractive to
workers
so skills are part and parcel of our
green deal industrial plan
we need to develop clean tech skills for
batteries for solar for hydrogen you
name it all these topics and here the
social Partners have the important role
to play
you the social Partners know best
you know best how to match people's
aspirations and their skills with the
company's needs that's a very fine web
that has to be woven
so our skills agenda relies very much on
the social Partners dialogue
it is accompanied by Massive investment
on the European level in skills around
65 billion euros from our mff and Next
Generation EU
finally
our Hallmark in Europe is our social
market economy
as I said at the beginning this balance
between prosperity and economic success
on one hand and social responsibility
and protection on the other hand this is
the source of the success of the single
Market
it has been the backbone of the single
Market over 30 years now
and these balanced Solutions too are
found between social partners and a
legislative framework that respects the
strong roles of social partners that is
in my view the recipe for Success
therefore our competitiveness strategy
goes hand in hand with a strong social
agenda thank you very much for the very
fruitful tripartite social Summit
thank you madam presidents prime
minister you have the flu thank you so
much and thanks jerusala for this
meeting and once again we have gathered
at very difficult times and of course
worst of all for for Ukraine and our
thoughts are with them
our Ukrainian friends but also our
actions are with them
people in businesses across Europe are
hit by high inflation High electricity
prices and fuel prices and we can also
see all the global consequences of
Russia's illegal War including food
charges
so the European Union together with the
business community and the unions and
the social Partners complete play a key
role in this situation
the Swedish EU presidency seeks to
promote as you know Greener safer and
Freer Europe and European long-term
competitiveness is obviously an
important priority in this regard at the
meeting today I emphasize that we are
all in the European Union that is member
states that is institutions that is
social partners and that is business
communities must do our utmost to live
up to our full economic potential and
we're not doing that right now both in
order to successfully fight the current
economic problems and to protect and
furthermore to develop long-term
European competitiveness
another topic of today's meeting was of
course how to fight the high inflation
now agonizing millions of European
families and at the same time to
implement structural reforms that
actually promote growth and promote
employment in both cases functioning
labor markets are key
and I especially welcome the fact that
the commission has made 2023 the year of
skills
skills and the collective capacity for
reskilling are extremely important to
mitigate both long-term demographic
change and shortages of employees in key
sectors across Europe
finally in fact even better
well-functioning labor markets and even
better skilled Workforce would be two
key preconditions for better European
competitiveness so let's use this
potential competitive advantage of
Europe thank you
thank you prime minister
Mr Frederick person the president of
business Europe please
thank you I from from the business side
I think the starting point for us is
that a strong resilient and prosperous
Europe stands on the foundation of a
competitive and growing business
the point we made is that we are in a
dire situation if we look at foreign
direct investments in Europe they're
down 60 while they're at the same time
are up 60 percent in the US talking to
our members 9 out of 10. say that they
see a worsening of investment situation
in in Europe
the recipe for that for us are four
points the first one is better
regulation decreasing the regulatory
burden making it easier to be
competitive in Europe
the second call out would be on energy
cost and finding a secure energy Supply
at an affordable cost that is good for
the European consumer it's good for
European business it's the foundation of
competitiveness
we also called out the need for a broad
industrial strategy
a strategy that works for smes for the
large companies regardless of where you
are in in Europe and here we would also
call out the skills the skills are an
extremely important part of this broad
industrial strategy
finally we called out the need for a
well-calibrated
subsidy situation subsidies will not
save Europe but in the transitionary
period especially with related to the
green transition there is the need for
short-term measures where we think the
TCF is getting it a good way on track
so summing it up I mean the call out
boss from the site on business and
industry we prepared to work on the
competitiveness and together build that
strong and resilient Europe thank you
thank you Mr person
Miss Lynch please thank you thank you so
the discussions tomorrow will be
critically important and that's why the
trade unions arrived to have the
discussion what we wanted to say was a
couple of things the first thing was we
need a vote of confidence that Europe is
somewhere to come and make things and we
see that very much in the recent uh
reports that have come out so we need a
strong vote of confidence to everyone
everywhere Europe's a great place to
come and invest we also wanted to have a
strong message about
jobs in Europe being great jobs
that we know for our children for our
grandchildren that we're putting in
place the necessary Frameworks so that
jobs will be great jobs good pay good
conditions the type of wages that you
can bring up a family on the type of
wages that you can look to the future
with confidence
um we also discuss what what what do we
mean by competitiveness because
competitiveness isn't just about a
single Enterprise it's about the whole
framework that that Enterprise sits in
it's about making sure that workers have
homes they can afford that they have
child care that they have schools that
they have health care that they have
transport to get to work all of that
needs to be part of the discussion
tomorrow and we we heard a lot of very
positive things in particular from
president vonderline about how the
discussions are going uh to take place
we also heard some things that worry us
and there are two things that worry us
and the first is this is not a time to
think that standards are holding us back
they're not
standards are part of our competitive
Advantage people like to buy things from
Europe because they can bite with
confidence
they know that's not going to poison
them they know that it's not that it's
not going to harm them that they and
they also know that it's been produced
without destructing the environment or
without causing harm to the worker and
that should be a competitive Advantage
not seen as a drag on competitiveness
yes we can get much better in how we
enforce but we don't need to start
rowing back on standards and try and
have a competitive advantage in relation
to a deregulation agenda so we're
encouraging the employers to think again
about that approach then finally I think
the real value
um of us all being here is it
demonstrates that every part has a role
to play workers were available to come
and discuss today about skills about how
we make the skills real for people but
how we make sure they get time off for
training how they can afford to do that
those how they can afford to do it about
about all of all of the approach that
will lead to competitiveness we're ready
we're available and we want to be part
of this solution and I think that that's
an important message that trade unions
and workers were part of this solution
thank you Miss Lynch
if there are any questions
from within the room
they're not there is please go to the
stand
and yeah
someone lets you out jump
[Laughter]
uh
thank you um Andreas on Swedish radio
um
you said that you subsidies will be
needed that they are well calibrated I
think you said so I would like to ask
well almost all of you
um even a commission president about the
proposals that have been made do you
think they are well calibrated when it
comes to subsidies would you like to see
more would you like to see less and also
on subsidies and estate 8
has been said that mainly two major
countries France and Germany can give
much more state aid than other countries
so do you think there is a need for more
EU level subsidies and a sovereignty
fund for instance so those are my
question for the business Community the
union and also maybe the Swedish prime
minister thank you
who wants to go first please go ahead
now I I think you're pointing to to the
key thing here which is well calibrated
uh we in business are entrepreneurs
competitiveness is not built on
subsidies
that said in a situation where you're
going through a substantial transition
specific targeted subsidies as is the
example under the temporary crisis
framework serve a very important purpose
I must say I think so far so good and I
think the IRA has been a wake-up call
for all of us and president Wonderland
used the wording that we needed to do
our homework I think for sure we've done
our homework if we reach the the grading
of A or B I think we're still in in the
process and we also need to be agile
with a lot of things happening but I I
think we're in a good place right now
then there will be differences for sure
between countries and we need to keep in
mind to to also protect the Level
Playing Field within the single Market
not only the devil playing field say
vis-a-vis the US
well I would say that the overall idea
with putting competitiveness on the
agenda is to not to say that immediate
measures are not necessary but they are
not sufficient
and I think we all know that we've been
dealing with immediate measures
sometimes crisis management for quite
some time now for good reasons that is a
skill that is needed but is not
sufficient so let's discuss uh the
things we know in the long run
will actually create or destroy European
competitiveness Ursula today mentioned
of course the levels of r d just to
mention one obvious item on the agenda
so I I don't see there is a they are
it's very possible to combine them but
of course in the long run you don't
build a successful business Community or
a successful welfare state on subsidies
but that is not to say that there might
not be cases where they are absolutely
needed for example to in a good way meet
the American the American initiatives I
think we have I think we are converging
in to some extent in a good way
so two things the first is there can be
no free checks
so when businesses get support there
needs to be a requirement that that
support goes towards making sure that
the jobs are quality jobs and that the
workers are also been invested in
workers need to know that when the
company has been supported there's an
obligation to support them too but
you're absolutely right there's a
difference between member states and we
need to make sure that the different
instruments that are being put in place
ensure that every region
every member State doesn't get left
behind because they're unable to provide
the necessary supports
yes thank you I think the subsidies or
incentives are well calibrated
first of all if you look at the global
Level Playing Field it as far as very
important that our companies and the
clean tech industry is being treated
fairly
we have agreed with our American friends
to have a transparency dialogue so we
know exactly what the incentives on the
American side are so that we can match
that here we should also keep in mind
there is a less transparent and
partially hidden subsidy uh there are
subsidies hidden and less transparent
from China where we also have to make
sure that we keep the Level Playing
Field for the European companies
now internally
within the single Market there also
needs to be a Level Playing Field and
therefore indeed state aid is
um has been shaped for temporary and
targeted
application
basically every member State can use
this dated but of course we know that
for some member states it's easier to
use state aid and others do not have the
room to maneuver financially to use
state it and therefore for me is
important our incentives are always a
coin with two sides on one side the
state aid on the other side there must
be common European funding here the
funds are different that are accessible
it's repower EU it's invest EU The
Innovation fund and we flexibilize the
cohesion funds
thus there is a wide variety of
possibilities either for member states
to give tax breaks to the cleantech
industry but also to incentivize
projects and most importantly to
incentivize cross-border pan-european
projects
thank you to all participants
for this press conference see you again
tomorrow thank you thanks again thank
you bye-bye thank you thank you